[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut tout le monde nouvelle vidéo est
aujourd'hui on va ré aborder un thème
qu'on a déjà vu dans une vieille vidéo
mais tout d'abord je vous propose une
petite mise en scène d'intro longueur
sujet
[Musique]
ok on va peut-être faire une vidéo plus
classique aujourd'hui fmv on avait déjà
parlé de sel il ya quelques années
souvenez-vous man enough police quest
soit cette époque grandiose et très
courte du jeu vidéo où tout le monde
voulait profiter du support cd pour
mettre le plus de vidéos possible dans
leur jeu
je suis gabriel knight je suis venu vous
voir au poste mais c'est drôle qui ne
m'ont pas laissé entrer
alors c'est vrai que quand on parle de
fmb on pense immédiatement à la période
1090 qui est la deuxième génération de
fmb mais qui est la grosse période de
popularité du genre les premiers fmv
sorte en 1983 le plus connu de cette
année-là et dragon's lair on en a déjà
beaucoup parlé beaucoup trop souvent
mais à peu près en même temps sortait
aussi un rail shooter du nom de astron
belt très bon
on va pas se le cacher c'est de la merde
c'est juste des images de vaisseau piqué
à deux films s'est fait une blague ce
genre là c'est du star trek et quand
vous touchez un truc ça lance une image
d'explosion mais j'en sais même pas
localisé sur le vaisseau que vous
touchez un c'est tout l'écran qui
explose à chaque fois que vous touchez
quelque chose aux gens ils s'en battent
tellement les couilles qui finissent
même pas les explosions il ya coupe
avant tarder à regarder bref on a déjà
parlé de quelques fmd à commencer par
knight rap le plus connu d'entre eux
mais beaucoup d'autres fmb son passé
sous le radar
a brillé ils sont presque tous passés
sous le radar d'ailleurs c'est un radar
très très haut par exemple on a critical
path un jeu qui se joue dans un monde
post apocalyptique comme nous le raconte
la voix off
nous sommes en 2040 le monde a été
envahie par une race de licorne
hélicoptère magique qui réduisent les
villans baba au rhum mais on n'a pas
beaucoup d'argent alors voilà plutôt une
image de flag bref le jeu consiste à
appuyer sur tout un tas de bouton au bon
moment pour guider la soldate lyon 2 4
qui s'est fait abattre avec son
hélicoptère et se retrouve perdu sur une
île dirigée par un diabolique dictateur
[Rires]
[Musique]
salut les amis c'est l'heure de jouer à
qui est le méchant si tu es stupide tu
fais demandé à tes parents ta rennes
à vrai dire le genre des fmb a été très
popularisé dans les années 90 par les
salles d'arcade
tous les gens de mon âge on forcément
croisé au moins une fois dans leur vie
une borne de mad dog macri est
d'ailleurs l'éditeur de ce jeu du nom de
american laser entertainement a sorti un
autre jeu dont je dois absolument vous
parler ces crimes patrol il s'agit là
encore d'un simple rail shooter c'est
aussi dans le monde de la police et de
la drogue vous y incarnez le jeu de
recrues qui vient d'arriver dans la
police municipale
la police municipale aux états unis
alors pour les gens qui ne connaissent
pas le principe d'un rail shooter à fmb
c'est très simple vous regardez une
vidéo des ennemis apparaissent si vous
tirez dessus à temps l'ennemi tombe au
sol et la vidéo continue parce que c'est
comme sexe et produits techniquement au
tournage se dressera ses droits la voir
c'est juste des gens qui se lèvent
grosse casse la gueule et par contre si
vous ne tirez pas à temps et bien le je
considère que vous avez perdu bref le
gameplay d'un rail shooter c'est
tellement simple que c'est impossible a
foiré
[Musique]
butra déjà pour commencer sachez que
craignent patronne n'a pas de points de
vie commune time crisis par exemple si
tu te prends une balle s'est perdu or
dans cry patrol le moment où le je
considère que vous avez perdu n'a aucun
sens avec ce qui se passe visuellement à
l'écran
je lui tire dessus la haie si je
mentionne ce problème c'est pas de la
mauvaise foi et c'est vraiment que ça
arrive tout le temps
arbitre un arbitre a fait appel à la
vidéo et
oui c'est confirmé je peux même pas à
prendre l'ordre par coeur pour anticiper
les ennemis parce qu'à certains moments
à septembre est aléatoire et qu'il ya
des innocents qui apparaissent devant
l'écran allez
j'ai failli refaire la connerie
quoi et en plus il arrive deux fois à
droite là ça veut dire quoi il a peur
complet et en plus des bugs parce que
techniquement c'est ce que c'est le jeu
entier pu la loose ils en ont rien à
[ __ ] un on voit l'ombre du cameraman
le ciel qui changent tout le temps le
micro qui tombe dans le champ le matelas
pour recevoir le cascadeur les
la gravité qui part en couille et plus
on avance plus ça se relâchent genre les
game over correspond même plus à
l'endroit où tu meurs lire la suite dans
un aéroport je meurs je suis dans un bar
est-ce que vous pouvez déposer à
l'hôpital or les acteurs j'en parle même
pas
le week end et
étaient en train d'avoir un avc
et puis évidemment je n'ai pas parlé du
scénario
c'est bon j'ai tué les drogues
si je vais toujours dans l'esprit de
club pour boire un bon nesquik
d'ailleurs comment c'est quoi là c'est
la danseuse et sourde ou alors ces gens
qui ont vraiment tout le monde s'en fou
de l'histoire quoi c'est ça et même les
gens qui sont dedans et attendez je vais
le réaliser mais en fait ils avaient
même rien compris à comment faire un fnb
le principe c'est de faire en sorte que
rien ne bouge à l'écran histoire que ce
soit crédible quand des ennemis
surgissent ensuite mais là vu que le jeu
fait varier l'ordre de sortie des
ennemis vous comprenez bien que s'il ya
une danseuse qui bouge tout le temps où
des nuages qui bouge tout le temps
forcément à l'image va sauter à chaque
nouvelle vidéo qui se lance
je sais pas moi georges méliès il avait
compris sa en 1902 bref on progresse
donc dans le scénario jusqu'à atteindre
la delta force qui s'occupe des gros
morceaux combler détournement d'avion
qui attendait
l'avion a été détourné mais quoi les
mecs qui sont rentrés comme ça un jour
et puis attendez je les tue ou c'est
juste qu'ils vont se rassoit je n'ai que
je tue et continue à bouger
ouah ok donc c'est officiel jean
n'importe quoi cet avion j'en suis à un
point où je m'attends à tout maintenant
bref c'est assez difficile de dire dans
les fmv où s'arrête le nanar et où
commence l'autodérision parce que
beaucoup de ces jeux à l'époque n'avait
pas beaucoup d'argent et avait
parfaitement conscience que le seul
moyen de ne pas être complètement
ridicule c'était de pas trop ce trop au
sérieux une autre technique sinon
c'était de profiter du tournage et des
acteurs d'un film pour tourner son jeu
fmv comme soldiers boy un film qui
raconte l'histoire d'une bande de jeunes
à qui on propose d'aller au vietnam en
échange d'une remise de peine et bien
pendant le tournage une seconde équipe
était chargé de réaliser le jeu fmv de
ce film on alterne donc les passages
tirés du film et les moments
spécialement filmer pour le jeu fmv je
vous laisse quelques secondes pour
deviner lequel est tirée du film pour
lequel ne l'est pas et après pour le
reste il s'agit juste de simples rail
shooter d'une classe incroyable
j'adore la langue vietnamienne c6
mélodique
voilà alors mention spéciale pour le
moment où vous allez dans une maison
close rempli de prostituées vietnamienne
et que vous devez trouver une capote
dans un jeu de bonneteau pour savoir
laquelle vous allez vous tapez
alors on prend qui la tiennent war lane
les trois on peut les 3 c'est pas cher
savait écouter par conscience
professionnelle je vais faire les trois
afin de finir le jeu à 100% après on va
pas leur jeter la pierre un c'était
souvent des petits réalisateur qui
voulait gagner un petit peu d'argent qui
s'occupait de ce genre de jours
[Musique]
ok alors j'ai pas de pierre a jeté alors
je peux jeter cette barre de gouvernail
si vous voulez après bon c'est pas donné
à tout le monde de pouvoir se greffer un
film pour faire son jeu alors si dans le
monde des fmb soldiers boys c'est
l'équivalent d'un blockbuster et bien
sachez qu'il existe aussi l'équivalent
des films d'auteur avec d'apt une mais
beaucoup d'idées bizarre quand on gate
sortie en 93 créée par greg roig de la
société hyper ball studio qui a créé un
concept révolutionnaire pour son jeu
appelé le
virtuel
c'est un peu comme de la vidéo et en
même temps quelque part c'est un jeu
s'ils ont fusionné les deux on pourrait
appeler ça virtual cinéma le jeu
commence par une intro sur fond de
musique triste pour te dire que les
humains ont pollué la planète à 2057
elle la terre sera bientôt incapable de
supporter la vie ça fait réfléchir alors
le genre lui même c'est moitié paul ten
clic moitié fmv on évolue dans un monde
extraterrestre ou en gros on doit sauver
la terre d'un complot ou j'sais pas quoi
l'histoire compliquée mais je résiste
pas à l'envié de vous montrer toute la
scène d'exposition
[Musique]
comment mais les transitions
artificielle personnes c'est quoi ces
gens pour dire un robot c'est qu'ils
avaient pas les moyens d'animer un vrai
robot dont ils ont juste pris quelqu'un
ils ont marqué ce que c'est censé
représenter c'est ça bonjour je suis un
tyrannosaure comme vous pouvez le
constater ok qu'est ce qui se passe
maintenant 2084 il ya une femme avec une
auréole
[Musique]
béatrice
béatrice j'vous jure j'ai aucune idée ce
qui est en train de se passer et c'est
quoi c'est peut-être là ça n'en coup
c'est pas vrai et c'est transition de
windows movie maker on dirait que
quelques a fait un film entier avec des
griffes de skyblog et qu'est ce que je
sais c'est qu'ils béatrice c'est celle
qui a fait le montage c'est ça cl ça
suffit pas délirer bon c'est moi le jeu
alors mettez à cinématique rome et à ce
jeu c'est un peu comme si tu allais au
musée tu payes ta place tu rentres dans
la galerie des tableaux et là tu
t'aperçois que tout le monde a juste
chier sur une toile c'est
indescriptiblement les pour un truc
sortie en 93
je sais je sais c'est un plat qui tourne
dans un micro-ondes
le moindre truc devient exercices de
compréhension pourquoi les personnages
sont juste des photos qui ont été
écrasés
c'est quoi c'est un faisceau spatiale ou
chf c'est quoi ces couleurs
pourquoi est-ce qu'elle a des léopards
derrière elle
s'est même pas juste ed ils ont oublié
d'incruster les décors sur la moitié des
plans et je vous parle même pas des
flashbacks que votre personnage fait
tout au long du jeu on dirait david
lynch qui s'est mis à faire des youtube
poop
ce qui se passe alors d'ailleurs pour la
petite histoire sur le wikipedia un
journaliste considère même ce jeu comme
la meilleure oeuvre de science fiction
depuis blade runner
d'accord donc d'après le journaliste on
a eu sa
[Musique]
et après il n'y a plus rien eu jusqu'à
ça
écoutez c'est vrai qu'on n'a peut-être
pas assez donné sa chance à la partie
gameplay du jeu on va revoir ça tout de
suite
[Applaudissements]
eh bien c'était la nuit je voulais aller
boire est lâché marcher sur l'un des go
alors d'ailleurs sachez que étonnamment
le jeu a été bien reçue il a une grosse
communauté de fans d'ailleurs est un
remake est prévue sur steam et d'après
une vidéo de promotion qui cite le
houston chronicle
pardon le créateur de ce jeu est le
nouveau steven spielberg
[Musique]
donc écouter si vous avez des
explications au nom de toute l'équipe
n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer un petit
mail on aimerait bien comprendre ma
théorie c'est je pense qu'à l'époque les
gens ont aimé le retournement de
situation de la fin du jeu que je
m'apprête à vous spoiler
puisque vous tout en foot je suis steven
spielberg et je m'en fous donc bref
avant tout je vous affrontez des
créatures dégueulasse avec un espèce
d'équipement de réalité virtuelle tout
se passe bien mais soudain vers la fin
vous fait défoncer par une des grosses
bestioles et devant votre défaite votre
armure de combat vous propose de vous
suicider en accord avec votre religion
donc judaïsme christianisme le
bouddhisme islam rien du tout ou un
mystère garçons une euthanasie à la
marocaine s'il vous plaît ok alors je
suis pas sûr qu'ils aient dû ouvrir
beaucoup de livres sacrés dernièrement
parce que je pense pas que le suicide ce
vous très apprécié dans les religions et
et puis de toute façon quoi si je
choisis chrétien il ya de romain qui
vont arriver en prêt sur une croix bref
donc bon je choisis le cadeau surprise
parce que j'adore batman et
d'asie points ex de réponse lui reboot
est le système en clignant 13 fois des
yeux rapidement ou éteignez le système
en fermant les yeux pendant 30 secondes
pendant que vous collez votre langue sur
le côté gauche de votre bouche et que
vous remuer votre nez
tandis que là mais attention révélations
maintenant que votre équipement et péter
vous pouvez enfin enlever votre casque
de réalité virtuelle et vous vous rendez
compte que plutôt que des grosses
bestioles dégueulasse vous étiez en
réalité en train de vous battre contre
des bots nas avec des ailes
l'événement ils sont pas humains ils ont
des ailes écoutez j'ai plus la force de
débats très jeune à ses vues pour
aujourd'hui allez salut tout le monde
je peux pas sortir en fait vivement la
fin du confinement
attends me dis pas que tu aies coincés
ici avec moi si si
très bien
[Musique]
donc toi aussi tu veux couper du bois
c'est j'arrête pas vos enfants
c'est étrange non on est en mai un peu
trop tôt pour couper du bois
vous occupez des feuilles marthaler
[Musique]
à